has been a rough couple of years in our
economy still rebounding from the
pandemic but with that recovery comes
inflation and higher prices now the
federal reserve says interest rates
could start climbing again soon sasha
loftis joining us live tonight to share
what could this mean for all of us right
here in las vegas
yes brian a lot of us have taken
advantage of these low interest rates
over the past few years but it looks
like that trend could soon change i
spoke with a local lending expert
tonight about what this could mean for
our city
i'm finally like relieved i can breathe
jamie snyder just bought a new house and
says she got a great deal i even told
him like how fast can you close this
she's one of many taking advantage of
historically low interest rates we've
been seeing over the past few years but
it looks like this trend could soon
change high prices fix high prices right
on wednesday the federal reserve pointed
to a rise in the federal funds rate as
early as march andrew levitt of pif
lending says with inflation raging this
is a way to even things out by just
increasing the cost to potentially
finance or obtain money
it's going to make people essentially
say hey maybe we don't need it but it
leaves many racing to lock down property
as home prices continue to rise setting
an all-time record in las vegas in
december at
425 thousand dollars on average levitt
added that interest rates could go back
down even if they see a spike but
overall costs will likely keep
skyrocketing 200 a month on an interest
rate that can change later potentially
versus a house that's 500 000 more five
years later it's a little different so
snyder says if you're able get under the
wire now and avoid any surprises in the
future buy as soon as you can i guess
now levitt said is it it is important to
remember that even if inter interest
rates go up in the next couple of months
they are still at the lowest rate we've
seen in around 70 years at about 3
percent for a conventional mortgage
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now